men have fought over the Riverlands
since the dawn age but that's to be
expected of things that rest below the
neck doesn't help that the Riverlands
are between everything and everything
else the westerland's gold that reaches
grain the vales rock and the North's
snow house mud once ruled as the kings
of the rivers and Hills but after a
thousand years their line was exhausted
and fell to the storm Kings who fell to
the arm as a boat of the years of
drowning at sea our rivers look pretty
attractive to that race of pirates and
rapers never mind that their monstrous
castle Harrenhal was too large to staff
and garrison it turned out the arm borne
wouldn't be there long enough to bother
Aegon Targaryen landed to our south and
as had many before him like the look of
the Riverlands my ancestor Edmund Tully
led the desertion of River laws to his
cause and was rewarded by getting to
watch King Haran burn in his own Tower
unfortunately that's not all Edmund got
house Tully was named the Lords
paramount of the Trident which means we
had to keep in line all those Lords who
hadn't governed themselves for thousands
of years we were they're responsible for
aiding the Masters at sea guard against
the pouting Ironborn whenever they got
cheeky
for settling harrenhal on family's
stupid enough to think it's curse would
skip them after devouring all previous
families for keeping the black hoods and
Bracken's from wiping each other out and
giving us two more castles to deal with
for keeping the phrase in their place
and out of others pockets for marrying
off our sons and daughters wisely enough
so we didn't follow house mud into well
the mud yet under the Targaryens the
Riverlands knew a piece we hadn't had
for centuries if ever but like all good
things sooner or later it all goes to
[ __ ] and our [ __ ] had a name Aerys
Targaryen Westeros has had its share of
mad kings but usually they have the
sense not to bully more than one
powerful house at a time
Aerys soon blundered into a Triple
Alliance the North Stormlands and Vale
rose against him but of course what do
you think most of the blood was spilled
my brother hosta guaranteed the answer
to that with a marriage of my niece to
Eddard Stark the warden of the north at
least ha student sent her to Robert
so the Riverlands joined the war against
the Mad King and it was on one of our
rivers that Prince Rhaegar died sealing
the fate of his dynasty
Robert was a great soldier and the
horrible king drinking and whoring our
own brand of madness when you sit on a
throne that everybody wants he died and
another war started again the armies
marched again the Riverlands burned if
Westeros isn't careful pretty soon our
people will grow some sense and abandon
this place for a safer realm like the
Dothraki sea a joke of course the
Riverlands are our home and gods help us
we love it still as they say the king
eats and the hand takes the [ __ ] the
same is true of the Riverlands the seven
kingdoms of piss and the Riverlands
change clothes